yesterday cnn aired a 16-minute
interview with the commissioner of the
nba
adam silver in cable news time
that's eternity and they needed it
because there's a lot to discuss
with silver not least the nba's long and
very close relationship with the
communist government of china the
government that's sending
minorities to re-education camps and
facilitating slave labor
but those questions never got asked
instead
a cascade of softballs watch
i assume you would cancel the nba season
adam if that was the right that would be
the right thing to do
if it involved the players health and
safety and other personnel
coaches etc uh you you would just end
the season right what will it be like
watching these games on tv to the cause
of racial justice in our country how do
you see the nba's role
and your role as commissioner when it
comes to supporting those players how do
you think whoever wins the nba title
should be remembered wow
how do powerful people get a pass from
the media
simple by being woke the nba painted
black lives matter
on its courts it allows its players to
kneel
for the national anthem giving the
finger to the country that made the
sport possible
burgess owens never kneeled when he was
professional athlete he joins us tonight
to respond
to all of this mr owens thanks so much
for coming on so what do you mean what
do you make of it
a a basketball league that has taken an
explicit
and partisan political position well
this is why i'm running
tucker burgess for utah.com uh what we
need to do is make sure we understand
who we're dealing with we talk about the
radical
left it's more than antifa it's more
than uh the the socialists in the
democratic
legislative legislation it's actually
the corporate cowards
that hide behind the misery of others to
to give them
a a way to get to their their bottom
line their bottom line is profit and
prof
uh profit and training power what uh
what the with the nba is a 1.5 billion
dollar contract
and they know that they're going to get
that they have to make sure that
that that they've caused havoc here and
get a president elected that will make
them make sure they get back to china
it's all about it's all
about november 2020 when it comes down
to democrats particularly this elitist
particularly
radical leftists who care less about
we're the people they don't care about
the blacks in the black community and
they don't care about the the chinese uh
uh people that are being uh oppressed in
china with slavery and and
uh child labor and a whole bit so you
know these people are really
there about themselves it's power and
power and profitability
nba in nfl nike they all fit the same
the same
mode they care less about we the people
corporate cowards hiding behind the
suffering of others i don't think i've
ever heard it better than you just
put it what quickly if you don't mind
what do you think this is doing to the
sport
itself it's dividing us the sport has
always been used to bring us together
that's that's the
that's the the the power of sports and
their flag and
in our national national anthem it
brings us together these folks
do not care about dividing do not care
about destroying their their game
their sport as long as they can get
their profitability if they get fighting
in there
they're into china they're into their
money and they can care less about the
rest of the country so keep in mind
these folks these are the the worst of
americans because they care
more about their profitability their
their growth in their and their power
again
they care about we're the people so
they're destroying their game they're
destroying cities
because they want to get inviting
elected in 2020.
i wish i could disagree with you bridges
owens thanks so much for coming on
tonight i really appreciate it
thank you thank you